So today we're announcing three new
measures to help people and businesses
firstly we're announcing a billion
pounds in financial Grant support which
means eligible hospitality companies
will be able to claim a cash Grant worth
up to six thousand pounds secondly we're
providing 30 million pounds to top up
our successful cultural Recovery Fund to
support institutions like theaters and
museums and lastly we're reintroducing
our statutory sick pay rebate scheme so
that small and medium-sized companies
can claim compensation for the
government for the cost of sick pay for
their employees taken together I'm
confident that these measures will help
hundreds of thousands of businesses and
the millions of people that they employ
um these are the restrictions as they
stand at the moment uh the uh the Prime
Minister was expected to announce some
tightening he didn't this is the sport
on offer now if there are further
restrictions announced will there be
more support on offer will people be
able to look at our track record over
the last year or two and supporting
people and businesses especially in the
hospitality industry throughout this
crisis now of course I will always
respond proportionately and
appropriately to the situation that we
Face people can have confidence in that
but where we are now we've responded I
think generously today the grants that
we've outlined up to six thousand pounds
are comparable to the grants that we
provided for Hospitality businesses when
they were completely closed earlier this
year so there's a benchmark for you also
it's important to remember we have
support already in place that lasts all
the way to next spring so for example A
reduced rate of vat for the hospitality
and tourism sectors and this year they
are benefiting from a 75 discount on
their business rates Bill those types of
things last all the way to next march to
support the industry